elon musk has said his 36 billion pound
takeover of twitter is temporarily on
hold so will that happen some have
accused him of not being entirely
serious about the bid from the start uh
let's get the latest from social media
expert matt navarra matt great to see
you this morning um well let's let let's
start with the practicalities of it what
exactly is it that elon musk is
complaining about at the moment but as
regards bot accounts on twitter why is
this a sticking point well this is all
the craziness of this deal he's come out
now this late hour and suggested that uh
twitter he's got concerns that there's
more than five percent which is the
amount of spam and uh bot accounts that
twitter has disclosed and it's disclosed
for some time he feels that he could be
more now and because he thinks there
could be more he wants to check that
because he's a bit concerned about
whether he wants to continue with the
deal but this is something that twitter
has disclosed many times and it's a
number that has been in their documents
and he had the opportunity as part of
the deal to do an advanced kind of due
diligence exercise before kind of
signing the contract and he chose not to
do it so it's rather surprising at this
late stage that he's throwing this
curveball in
rather surprising i'm wondering if
euphemistically you are perhaps
suggesting that he might not have been
entirely serious about this from the
get-go certainly there are a lot of
people who are coming to that conclusion
yeah there's lots of competing theories
as to why he's saying this now one of
them is that he you know the tech stocks
have taken a huge hammering on the
markets recently and the value of
twitter has dropped significantly and
also the value of his own tesla stocks
which he's using to fund the deal has
gone down making the deal even more
expensive so it could be that this is a
angling for a way to back out of the
deal it could be he's angry to get a
discount on on the price of of twitter
but also he's very unpredictable and
kind of likes to be the center of
attention with this sort of stuff and it
could just be it was friday the 13th and
elon musk wanted to have some fun
yeah yeah there is that of course you
know elon musk has been talking an awful
lot about donald trump recently donald
trump has been talking about elon musk
he makes the point and you've got to say
donald trump does know a thing or two
about large sums of money he makes the
point that from his perspective twitter
was overpriced i mean is there perhaps
some truth in that
uh possibly and you know twitter has got
lots of issues not not only the fact
that this deal is such a mess but you
know it could be fair to say that that
it has been overpriced and that there is
some
possibility that uh a discount could be
uh could be reasonable but at this stage
in in the proceedings and given all the
things that go on so far it's just yet
another kind of nightmare problem for
twitter which whatever happens with this
deal twitter is the one that's going to
be the loser in all of this and and of
course the staff that work for the
company and the users that love the
product it really is a complete and not
a mess
yeah just just on that point then is it
perhaps is perhaps the reason this deal
has stalted something rather more
present rather more straightforward in
fact actually you know for all his hopes
of turning it into some kind of free
speech utopia the practicalities
surrounding doing that would almost make
it impossible
i think he's slowly coming to the
realization potentially that this is not
going to be as straightforward as maybe
he first thought you know some of his
language he's used in interviews
recently about content moderation and uh
the fact that he met the even one of the
eu leaders to do with the regulation
that the eu's bringing in and the fact
that he will you know align twitter to
that follow some of those rules so shows
a little bit of nuance in the fact that
he's going to have to sort of bend to
what is going to be needed for for
managing such a complex um content
platform like twitter so i do think that
that he may have bitten off more they
can chew and it could be one step that
he's taking now to kind of step away
from from this nightmare situation
matt navarro good to talk to you this
morning have a lovely weekend thank you